il s'appelait robert micheline odette
monique chantal sylvia quatre lignes et
patrick ce soir on vous raconte la
troublante histoire d'enfants disparus
dans les années 70 aussi l émission le
dossier noir du lavage des mains dans
les hôpitaux au québec
bienvenue à enquête
bonsoir mesdames messieurs on a deux
enquêtes pour vous ce soir les
reportages de gino harel et anne
panassac and en deuxième partie
d'émission
vous avez enquêté sur la disparition de
huit enfants
ça s'est passé à pas quoi chipie une
petite communauté innu de l'extrémité
est du québec
les enfants ont disparu il ya 40 ans mes
parents ne l'ont jamais revue
mais on a éclairci le mystère on vous
retrouve un peu plus tard gino vous
avait compilé des milliers de données
des hôpitaux québécois sur le lavage des
mains puisqu'on a appris nous permet de
croire que les leçons de l'épidémie
c'est difficile en 2004 n'ont peut-être
pas toutes été apprise encore
aujourd'hui une majorité de gens dans
les hôpitaux ne se lave pas les mains
quand il le faut on regarde votre
reportage avait eu un diagnostic d'un
polype au côlon en 2010 un séjour à
l'hôpital bouleverse à jamais la vie de
steve gagné et de sa conjointe
madeleine boulet sept changements
devaient prendre à peu près
quand trois jours avec la stérilisation
une infection fait tout basculer
je comprenais pas parce que franchement
je le sais dissimulé maladie ne convient
pour moi cette école
pour les personnes âgées depuis dix ans
les hôpitaux ont pourtant rehaussé leurs
précautions en prévention des infections
likoud de processus piste thématiques
ont été mis en place le toto 13e suicide
dans la province sont très stables
depuis sept ans mais chaque année encore
des milliers de personnes attrapent
d'une infection à l'hôpital sur ce qu'on
peut en faire beaucoup plus madeleine
boulet cherche des réponses
je vous comprends je veux comprendre
c'est le 2 mars 2010 quelques jours
avant son 47e anniversaire de naissance
que steve gagny subi son opération à
l'hôpital saint françois d'assise à
québec
la chirurgie se déroule bien mais
quelques jours plus tard les choses se
compliquent la 5e journée
il y avait la douleur atroce ils
répondent épervier était plus l'eau et
alors là j'ai sonné l'alarmé je te le
voir le personnel mais ont lancé le code
bleu parce qu'effectivement est en train
de mourir
on est venu me trouver venir écouter
passera par la nuit alors on doit
l'opérer d'urgence plus en droit lui
enlever les colons complet et on finit
par découvrir que steve avait contracté
là c'est difficile
après six semaines d'hospitalisation et
diverses complications
steve gagné reçoit son congé le
lendemain il succombe à une embolie
pulmonaire
le rapport du coroner fait référence à
son séjour prolongé à l'hôpital
officiellement il n'est pas vendu assez
difficile mais madame boulet boîte un
lien dans cette suite de complications
adaptation de colomb vote comment pas de
chrome os mais pas d'aliments pendant
pratiquement 40 jours donc au bout du
compte on abolit
nous la télé que dennis silencieux
beaucoup mais on n'a pas un peu en
janvier 2004 un reportage de l'émission
en jeu sonne l'alarmé sur les infections
à l'hôpital
ça l'a vraiment mis les infections
nosocomiales sur la nappe c'était
quelque chose qui était inconnu du
public dans les mois qui suivent la
crise du clostridium difficile éclate au
québec alors entre le mois d'août et le
mois de novembre de la bactérie c
difficile à fait eu d'autres victimes
merci il ya eu trois gros année
d'épidémie de 2004 a donné 7 environ ça
a été le vif de l'épidémie en 2005 le
rapport au coin propose de nombreux
moyens pour prévenir et contrôler les
infections nosocomiales
au fil des ans les mesures se sont
multipliés je voudrais que j'ai
énormément
fait de démarche en sus j'avais besoin
de comprendre makhzen boulet soupçonne
que des problèmes persistent elles
consultent de nombreux documents dont le
rapport au coin puiser l'adresse
diverses plaintes à l'hôpital saint
françois d'assise pour regarder enfin
quand le travail en général le travail
du personnel
elle poursuit même l'hôpital au civil
aux dossiers de la cour on constate
qu'un règlement est intervenu le
printemps dernier
les détails sont confidentiels mais
c'est avec des demandes d'accès à
l'information que madeleine boulet
confirment ces premiers doutes sur les
lacunes des hôpitaux
il ya des outils qui serait par rapport
lavage des mains maintenant donc je suis
allé vérifier auprès de différents
hôpitaux pour avoir une idée de ce qui
se fait ailleurs aussi que vous dire que
c'est beau les hôpitaux vérifie si leur
personnel se lave les mains surtout à
deux moments précis avant un contact
avec un patient ou son environnement et
après le contact en 2013
à saint françois d'assise à peine une
personne sur cinq 18% du personnel
observaient se laver les mains avant et
27% après il ya encore beaucoup de
travail à faire c'est une cuisse sera
changé les choses se sont améliorées
depuis
mais les dernières données disponibles
pour les 5 hôpitaux du chus de québec
dont fait partie c'est françois d'assise
affiche tout de même un taux de
conformité et l'hygiène des mains de
seulement 26 % avant et 40% après le sud
de québec ne commente pas le cas
particulier de style gagner ou h
considère que les systèmes de prévention
qu'on a actuellement sont efficaces et
son billet c'est sûr que chaque cas
d'infections nosocomiales pour moi est
un peu trop
valérie dancause est responsable de la
prévention des infections
elle ne se préoccupe pas que du lavage
des mains mais aussi de tout ce qui peut
empêcher la propagation d'infections
notamment la salubrité et la
désinfection des news et équipements et
le respect des précautions autour des
patients porteurs ou à risque
on travaille à trouver multiples
facettes pour pour justement à contrer
entraîné 1000
les taux de ces difficiles sont en
baisse à l'hôpital saint françois
d'assise
c'est le cas aussi pour la moyenne des
hôpitaux du québec en 2014 2015
la province comptaient 3453 cas de
diarrhées associées aussi difficile
c'est près de deux fois moins qu'il ya
dix ans l'institut national de santé
publique du québec surveille aussi
l'évolution des patients pour déterminer
combien décèdent dans les 30 jours
suivant le diagnostic de ces difficiles
l'an dernier ce nombre était de 547 cela
ne signifie pas pour autant que tous ces
décès étaient nécessairement attribuable
aussi difficile
les taux de ce treizième succès dans la
province ont atteint les taux les plus
bas des 5 dernières années
nous avons à notre tour envoyé des
demandes d'accès à l'information dans
les hôpitaux
près d'une centaine l'hygiène des mains
est ressorti comme un problème dans
plusieurs établissements
à montréal par exemple un institut de
réadaptation affichait en 2014
un taux de 8,2 pour cent avant contact
avec le patient un risque pour la
sécurité de la clientèle selon ce
document
un enjeu aussi à l'hôpital maisonneuve
rosemont cd rappelle à tous les jours ça
dérape elle constat lors d'observations
en 2014
cinq des dix neuf unités de l'hôpital
affichaient des taux de 0% avant contact
avec le patient
on tombe toujours un peu rebelle notre
chaise et quand on voit des héros c'est
sûr que dès que c'est fait on avis tu
cite le chef d'unité maisonneuve
rosemont a depuis remonté ses taux pour
l'ensemble des unités à 30 2% avant
contact et 43% après
pourquoi est souvent plus bas avant
qu'après les gens veulent se protéger
donc les gens vont davantage se laver
parce que l'on touche à l'usagé parce
que sont allés dans la chambre demande
même au travers de la santé imaginez que
votre mère qui dans le lit je crois vous
accepteriez d'avoir les infirmières ou
les médecins se laver les mains juste
une fois sur deux lorsqu'il la soigne
malgré les faibles taux de conformité
le docteur longtin voix des progrès vous
dirai sur l'échelle de 10 ans à
l'hygiène des mains on est passé de la
préhistoire à l'ère moderne à l'hôpital
du haut-richelieu des documents nous ont
permis de voir les détails d'une crise
vécue de 2012 à 2014
en deux ans 255 personnes ont été
infectées par le sedif is il sait ce que
c'est une période qui nous a pris aussi
beaucoup la situation était la pire en
montérégie depuis la crise de l'hôpital
honoré-mercier de saint-hyacinthe en
2006 ça a pris
différents je dirais catégories de
mesures tant au niveau des médicaments
au niveau de l'environnement qu'au
niveau de l'hygiène des mains
en plus d'augmenter la fréquence des
désinfections l'hôpital a réalisé plus
de 55000 observations sur l'hygiène des
mains
dans la seule année 2013 2014 il a
d'ailleurs fallu sévir contre certains
employés qui ne se lavait pas les mains
quand ça fait une fois deux fois trois
fois qu on avise la personne et que
c'est carrément de la non volonté de
respecter la procédure
à ce moment là c'est dans notre devoir
d'appliquer des mesures disciplinaires
le personnel n'appréciait pas toujours
d'être ainsi surveiller partir du moment
où il voit quelqu'un qui observe existe
plutôt que d'observer observée vient dom
et d où l l'autre commentaires qu'on
pouvait entendre c'est fatiguant de
toujours se faire regarder comment qu'on
travaille pas aujourd'hui à
saint-jean-sur-richelieu
le taux de lavage des mains atteint 83%
avant contact avec le patient et 88%
après
parfois d'autres problèmes se posent
quand des gens par exemple porte des
gants de protection en oubliant que ces
mêmes camps peuvent propager les
bactéries souvent les gens mettent des
gains qui gardent les mêmes gars pour un
livre war pierre changeant et aux spurs
et ça arrive encore aujourd'hui ça
arrive énormément au jour dans tous les
milieux
après la pause les résultats de notre
grande enquête sur le lavage des mains
dans les hôpitaux
un constat inquiétant
j'ai mis l'argent des comptes m la toile
et 2 font tant en fonction depuis ce
matin la chef d'unité isabelle girard
demande de l'aide à chantal bellerose
pour faire réparer des appareils de
nettoyage
quand on arrive sur le département les
gens viennent nous voir sont intéressés
à nous qui viennent pizza j'aurai une
question ya il m'est arrivé ça les gens
de la prévention des infections ne chôme
pas à travers les campagnes de
vaccination où les problèmes dans leur
traitement de dispositifs médicaux
il y à la surveillance de nombreuses
infections et bactéries résistantes aux
antibiotiques
à québec cinq ans après le décès de son
conjoint madeleine boulet a trouvé
beaucoup d'informations sur les enjeux
entourant les infections nosocomiales
une expérience cependant ardues - on
m'avait carrément avisé que je ne misais
possiblement au bon fonctionnement de
choc suite à mes demandes de
d'accès à l'information devrait avoir
plus de transparence
le dos et les hôpitaux fonctionnent avec
vos impôts des taxes fonds p&g dire si
c'est difficile pour qu'on sait pas
l'institut national de santé publique du
québec publie plusieurs rapports annuels
sur diverses infections nosocomiales
celui de 2014 2015 pour le si difficile
montrent les données analysées pour
l'ensemble de l'année mais pas
l'évolution de moins en mois le
clostridium difficile et surveillé nidal
and lourd au québec le docteur longtemps
se faire rassurant sur la qualité du
système québécois la surveillance
québécois ce que ce régime difficile est
probablement la plus vieille au monde
c'est une chose présenter leur allait
donner une fois par année au public
mais c'est une autre chose de se
rappeler que les données sont utilisées
en tout temps 12 non par année on les
surveille
ailleurs au pays plusieurs provinces
publie sur internet leur taux de ces
difficiles et l'hygiène des mains
l'ontario va plus loin pour chaque
hôpital on peut voir neuf indicateurs
dont les taux de ces difficiles
mise à jour chaque mois et les taux
d'hygiène des mains avant et après
contact avec le patient
depuis 2009 et là notre niveau ça n'a eu
que des effets positifs partout en
ontario
le microbiologiste et infectiologue
hexagone et patron à l'hôpital de
belleville
il a été co président du comité
consultatif ontarien sur les infections
nosocomiales
pendant plus de dix ans il était en
poste en 2008 quand l'ontario a rendu
obligatoire la divulgation d'indicateurs
sur la sécurité des patients il s'agit
ici de la confiance du public
oui cette confiance exige qu en tant
qu'hôpital financé par le contribuable
nous fassions preuve de transparence sur
l'hygiène des mains par exemple son
hôpital se situe présentement autour des
90 % de conformité avant la divulgation
obligatoire
les taux étaient beaucoup plus bas quand
on a commencé nos taux était à 35%
c'était gêne d'avoir publié c'est tout
vous croyez que ça a joué un rôle dans
les changements d'habitude je le crois
ça met une pression sur un hôpital
public
mais le fardeau sur tout le monde arabe
république les patients les visiteurs
aussi on doit tous se laver les mains
alors c'est un changement de culture
challenge en ontario aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des taux de lavage des mains
frise des 90% santé publique ontario
reconnaît que les chiffres sont peut
être gonflé par le fait que le personnel
se sait souvent observé une étude en a
d'ailleurs fait la démonstration à
toronto
si vous avez quelqu'un avec une planche
est en train de vous observez ça va
avoir un effet il n'ya rien de mal à ça
on reconnaît si on le fait toujours de
la même façon et qu'on passe de 35 à 95%
c'est quand même une grosse amélioration
de publier les taux d'hygiène des mains
façon facilement accessible pour le
public pourrait inciter les hôpitaux qui
ont les taux les plus faibles à se
réveiller un peu l'eau puis à faire à
trouver des solutions pour améliorer
leur taux de confiance a dit gêné mais
les comparaisons était hospitalisé il
faut juste s'assurer que c'est le même
nom mais c'était la même façon de façon
plus comparer des pommes avec des pommes
au québec les hôpitaux on n'évalue pas à
l'hygiène des mains de manière uniforme
nous avons tous le même produit un outil
accessible sur notre site internet à
partir des données que nous avons
recueillies nous y avons regroupé les
taux de conformité avant et après
contact avec le patient pour près de 90
établissements québécois
vous pouvez ainsi voir les taux de
lavage des mains dans votre hôpital
la comparaison des taux de 6 difficiles
entre le québec et l'ontario et
laborieuse en raison des compilations de
données différentes
on sait cependant que l'ontario a réduit
par centaines sont au nombre de cas ces
dernières années
santé publique ontario croit que
l'amélioration de l'hygiène des mets a
probablement joué un rôle au québec
lee et respectueux a lancé l'an dernier
dix ans après la crise de 2004 une
campagne de soins sécuritaires avec
diverses stratégies de prévention des
infections
on avait à ce moment là en 2004 près de
21 mille patients annuellement qu'ils
étaient infectés l'eau par une infection
nosocomiale et tous les mesures qui ont
été implantés ont permis de réduire
selon à moins de 2 km où on a des
résultats courrières docteur galarneau
crois que cette baisse a permis de faire
passer le coût de ces infections de 350
à 250 millions de dollars par année
notre objectif mon objectif est de
réduire de 30% encore et pour ce faire
mais l'or je voudrais que nos ressources
sont utilisées à leur maximum
il faut maintenant pour faire plus les
outiller elle parle notamment
d'informatique mais aussi de ressources
en pharmacie pour s'assurer d'une
utilisation adéquate des antibiotiques
honnêtement si on avait deux trois
personnes depuis
et
je pense que ça serait bienvenu les
ressources en prévention des infections
ont été établis en 2004 je convaincu
qu'il devrait avoir un travail pour
évaluer les ressources en prévention
puis puis revoir à la hausse les besoins
en prévention des infections sont plus
forts plus plus grand en 2015 qu'ils et
en 2004 c'est une décision aussi qui
relève un peu de la politique en ce sens
que le ministère de la santé des
services sociaux doit prioriser parmi
les priorités
si je sens qu'il ya davantage de
ressources nécessaires en investira mais
pour le moment je pense qu'avec les
ressources qu on peut faire mieux
québec mise aussi sur des mesures
prévues dans le plan d'action
ministériel 2015 2020 qui vise notamment
l'élimination des chambres à plusieurs
lits avec salles de toilette partager on
veut en venir à avoir des chances un
autant que possible
nous avons soumis à la ministre
charlebois quelques-unes de nos données
sur les taux de lavage des mains dans
les hôpitaux du québec le ministère fixe
la cible à 80% la vaste majorité des
installations en sont loin
certaines même très loin
particulièrement avant contact avec le
patient et samedi qu'on y travaille
enfin samedi que beaucoup de prévention
enfin c'est samedi que bah écoutez un
peu un peu puis j'aimerais voir le corps
mal de contrats étaient fermés
honnêtement c'est l'équipe du belge
avoue quoi je ne mets pas en doute votre
parole 6e elle n'envisage pas pour
autant de commencer à faire publier ce
type de statistiques
ben je vous dis pas que ça arrivera
jamais mais je vous dis que pour le
moment c'est pas ça sur lequel le
dossier sur lequel on travaille
ces derniers mois madeleine boulet a
porté sa bataille jusqu'au ministère de
la santé elle a rencontré les gens du
ministère pour proposer la création d'un
fonds d'indemnisation pour les victimes
d'infections nosocomiales
comme il en existe ailleurs en france
par exemple pourquoi qui ne citerai pas
quelque chose pour supporter les gens
qui disent des maladies nosocomiales ep
qui se ramasse avec des séquelles ou
avec d'autres problèmes un sou est un
sou parce qu'on vaut pas l'hôpital pour
attraper des bactéries la ministre
charlebois expriment de la compassion
pour les gens qui comme madame boulet
vivre ce genre de situation mais le
programme n'est des mises à sion n'est
pas dans les plans la prévention ça
arrête d'en déployer les ressources
prévenez pour qu'il n'est plus une
maladie nosocomiale autant que possible
déçu de la réponse de la ministre
madeleine boulet ne regrette cependant
rien de sa démarche
j'ai fait un travail de recherche avec
le moyen j'avais ça m'a fait du bien de
l'enfant
alors je
je souhaite que ça débouche quelque
chose de positif je suis fier d'avoir
fait posting steve aurait fait la même
chose pour vous
gino madame boulet elle est très déçu de
la réponse de la ministre elle veut
continuer à se battre
elle frappe maintenant à la porte du
ministère de la justice du québec dans
l'espoir de convaincre les gens de ce
ministère de créer un fonds
d'indemnisation
le programme d'indemnisation y en a en
france depuis plusieurs années déjà est
un programme qui prévoit des
compensations importantes dans les cas
graves d'infection nosocomiale
merci et on vous invite à les visiter
l'outil en ligne qu'on a créé suivi
savoir si les gens dans l'hôpital près
de chez vous se lave les mains toutes
les données sont là ceux sur notre site
internet reste avec nous parce qu'après
la pause on vous raconte la terrible
histoire de ses enfants disparus dans
les années 70 dans l'indifférence
générale les autorités attribuent